thouars voilà non moi je trouve voilà
moi je vous aviez dit que vous auriez le
césar vous l'avez eue là je pense que
vos parents vont être aux anges
oui mais ils sont aux anges ainsi dans
votre jeu présente la météo y trouve sa
sublime
voilà c'est vrai que l'appartement à
dunkerque a été transformée en musée sur
s'amuser on peut visiter un ouais ouais
non mais c'est vrai on puisse
s'appliquer à tous les moyens les
affiches
il ya même l'enveloppent canton entre
eux mais césar dont on on est dans une
enveloppe et qu'on m'avait glissé dans
la poche c'est pas qui me l'a dit c'est
l'assistant choix sur le plateau mes
parents l'ont gardée l'ont encadrée donc
c'est à la maison
à quel âge avait pris conscience de vos
qualités d'acteur comme ça depuis je
suis petit j'ai envie de faire ça oui
mais j'ai pas qu'on soit de qualité et
son film oui oui voici mais là j'ai
compris la temps en temps je vais rater
aussi depuis hwa depuis je suis gamin
j'ai jamais pensé faire autre chose en
fait c'est vrai que vous faisiez des
exposés à l'école son troisième reich en
limitant laspalès oui j'avais fait un
exposé comme comme je n'avais pas
beaucoup de contenu j'avais pas
travailler enfin pour faire rire j'ai
voilà j'ai fait un exposé sur troisième
reich ont ils tant à ce palais cela va
marcher courir mes camarades et leurs à
13 ans ont fait le siège du nord agitait
dans une école extrême droite en face à
13 ans ont fait le siège d'une radio
locale à dunkerque s'appelle radio
corsair jusqu'à ce qui vous donne une
émission de dimanche matin vous avez
bien je suis rentré je faisais à
l'époque s'appelait pouces disque serait
allé quand on est à la radio on parlait
pas en fait on enchaîne les disques et
après ouais j'ai commencé à parler dans
le micro à 15 ans quoi je faisais de 15
ans à 18 ans fait une bonne vanne cette
époque-là sur les employés de la mairie
on s'est fait virer d'ailleurs à cause
de ça on avait dit ce que la radio c'est
une radio locale dont qui était
évidemment financé par la ville
ouais voilà et on avait dit pour
pourquoi les employés de la mairie de
dunkerque ne regarde pas la fenêtre le
matin parce qu'il serait plus quoi faire
la salle elle n'a pas fait marrer en
fait je crois quoi et le premier adjoint
je suis un qui a débarqué dans les
studios c'est inadmissible mieux que ça
ils étaient plus naturel
là vous n'êtes pas payé vous avez pas de
jouer comme normal un nom vous dit c'est
la santé il sait comme ça avec sans
façon dont un pour la 1ère radio est
alors votre premier succès c'est en
seconde
bizarrement dois dire et là vous avez
joué une pièce écrite par deux copains
et ça voilà vous êtes rendu compte que
vous aviez vraiment des capacités de la
sidr quoi ouais c'est là où ça m'a plu
on l'a joué bon puis c'est la conscience
était hanté en seconde et tu joues
devant 800 personnes
un être plein et rend compte de rien et
je me suis rendu compte que c'était pas
mal quoi c'est ça me plaisait et qu'est
ce qui vous a décidé à venir à paris je
voulais vie en fait je voulais lui dire
depuis depuis toujours mais mes parents
on dit il faut faire des études toujours
le même truc dont je suis parti à lille
j'ai fait des études pendant trois ans
et j'avais une camarade de classe de 2
dunkerque qui était rentré au cours
florent et je suis allé le retrouver en
fait au moment des vacances de noël je
suis allé voir les courses et isabelle
nanty qui donnait coin
j'ai appelé mes parents disant voilà je
veux plus retourner à la fin que je veux
rester là quoi ils ont été super parce
que parce que c'est pas évident quand il
vient de province n'est pas d'un milieu
aisé la vie à paris c'est quand une
chaire est donc voilà vous avez une
chambre de bonne qui fait 6 mètres
carrés dont 12 12
ouais c'est un peu ses douze mètres
carrés dans le xvième amis de versailles
c'est être au dessus de chez elisabeth
les deux sens financier est alors votre
maire tous les week-ends vous fait un
petit panier pour la semaine parce que
j'avais pas de sous je pouvais pas
acheter tout ça c'est trop cher c'est
impossible
donc je rentrais le week-end à dunkerque
et ma mère me préparer des plats dans
des tupperware pour la semaine entre la
gare du centre national du livre à 23
ans
ouais exactement mais ça permettait de
bouffer mais vous y croyez toujours à ce
moment là ouais ouais ouais et des
moments tu crois moi c'est sûr mais
n'ont ni toit j'ai toujours cru je me
battais quoi on monte des pièces avec
les copains on se débrouillait c'est
comme ça qu'on a fait la pièce des
robins des bois voyait pas de table donc
sur les débrouillés en fait le déclic ça
a été j'ai eu escaut sinon c'est les
robins des bois la pièce le déclic et
farrugia qui vient nous voir c'est la
date à wemmel a tout de suite mais voilà
et aujourd'hui vous faites des films
avec depardieu quand même bon de temps
vous avez la vedette way qui sort le 23
février qui s'appelle je préfère qu'on
reste amis
et puis à boules dû sauver des eaux si
j'ai un petit rôle à ses participations
en souvenir et jugnot de justement de
batignolles il m'a demandé de faire un
petit truc devant ouais c'est vrai bien
entendu attends tu rigoles je suis ravi
mais vous jouez bien jean-paul merci
n'écoute pas les gérants des genoux très
bien